girls always ask questions like that
yeah and then they find out things they
don't work you know what you don't
probably actually happened he was going
like this
and then she's like oh what are you
thinking about
and then it was over after that
[Music]
back in 2017 there's a guy named Tony
Parsons who's uh age 63. he disappeared
right in this remote Scottish
Countryside area and he probably wanted
to
you probably want to escape the the
hustles is that right is he DB Cooper no
he's not but that's such a good story
right there
um he just disappeared which left police
which left his friends and family can
like totally like you know when you when
you have [__] questions that don't
get answered you're just unsettled and
it's just a mystery right it's a good
way to feel wanted recently uh in a high
court uh attendees heard how a this
much-loved grandfather was tragically
killed actually in a late night drunk
driving accident right appearing in
court the guy Alexander McKellar
admitted to hitting Parsons in his Isuzu
D-Max pickup uh on this highway in this
bridge area in September 2017. he got
[__] scared and stuff because he was
driving drunk and all that stuff so he
wanted to hide the Murder By [__]
digging up a hole with his buddy and
then burying this dude right damn this
hole ended up being what is called a if
you guys are familiar with this term
which I had to Google because I was like
what the [__] is this a peat bog
basically a bog that like you know is
almost like a swamp yeah it has like all
this yeah so they bury this guy in there
uh including his belongings and then
nobody knows like what happened where's
uh where this guy is eventually though
this dude uh the murderer gets into this
you know relationship some chick and
then he confesses because everybody's
always eventually going to confess right
what an idiot and he even goes and shows
her where it is oh what that's the
stupidest thing ever that's a true
weirdo move we're all trying to back up
like you shouldn't have done it so the
secret stuff well we always you know
because he's the main characters are
trying to be on his side yeah and
[__] chicks can't keep a secret he
wants you to get away with it dude we're
on your team there's nothing chicks
can't keep us secret they can't they
can't especially when it has to do with
murder especially you ever asked your
chick like if you find out I murdered
somebody would you snitch on me they
always say yeah yeah
so just me it's just me to ask my wife
this question no would it be the other
what about the other way around I
wouldn't snitch
yeah yeah
that's all the boys and then one of our
wives is gonna say something like Nikki
he's kind of dead and then the boys
would talk until they're wise and then
and one of the wives would say something
spread it again it all goes back dude
this is yeah the boys the wives read it
again what's your explanation of Nikki
it was an OTR topic
I had to [__] say something I I was
looking at the clock and I was like I
got nothing bro let me ask the room if
any of those others ever killed anybody
I had to say yes it was the boys
I said you're a cute little murderer
though
this woman what she does in her snitch
attempt right Bart's gonna tell you
exactly what she does
give me the location first people keep
bogging Glasgow what did the girl do
what did the new girlfriend do step by
step their girlfriend or a wife I
believe it's just a girlfriend new
girlfriend okay like couple months maybe
so the new girlfriend she goes on Google
and she goes how do you make sure no one
finds out and then she types because all
girls are bimbos but types out her
boyfriend's first and last name uh
didn't kill anybody and that's how the
cops find out that it was this guy
because the first and last Google
searched this yeah but she was in
incognito mode that's what she said if
she's incognito mode they don't have
hair you can't [__] catch it they
can't see it no [__] Trace dude I
don't think girls are used to incognito
mode because they don't have very little
use of it they don't know what they
don't even know about it
very low reasons why women should use
incognito mode only travel vloggers know
because they use it to purchase tickets
little known fact I didn't know that
actually I didn't know that I thought I
was just using it why do they do that
that's what I thought too did they log
in your cookies and then they go oh
you're really trying to go to Spain this
year aren't you um
I should be on Incognito right now uh
that being said this quote unquote quick
thinking woman what she actually did was
there was an empty Red Bull can that was
in that car and so in that area of the
site she just dropped the Red Bull can
and then she gives an anonymous tip to
the police even worse I give her too
much benefit of the doubt I thought she
was gonna try to help cover him up wait
she wrote something in the Red Bull cab
no she just dropped the Red Bull can as
a marker like an x marks the spot type
of thing yeah and then gave an anonymous
tip to the police in 2020 about like
look for the rebels and saying look for
the Red Bull can you imagine she goes
look for the rebel can and in there
you'll find directions to the place
you might ask how I wrote it
you will find over there a Shasta bottle
you think you think this guy was like
you know what I think it's time to take
this relationship to the next level and
I gotta level with her yeah and then
she's all like it's a gangster Next
Level though because maybe she was like
you know I hope you were more open with
me like I just want to know the real you
and he goes oh you do I want you to love
me for me and then like would you love
me if you knew the real me yeah yeah
that's dude Right girls always ask
stupid ass questions like that yeah and
then they find out things they don't
work out or you know what you know
probably actually happened he was going
like this
and then she's like oh what are you
thinking about
and then it was over after that it's
over yeah oh I was thinking about how I
murdered a guy one night and they
started they started fighting about he
never communicate with me I don't
communicate they come here yeah you want
to know about me come with me it's like
yeah you murdered a guy whatever Brett
you didn't [__] murder a guy
practically I did motorcycle [__]
show you [__] I'll [__] show you
exactly yeah just like you're such a
[__] I'm a [__] you've never killed
anybody in your life he's like I'll
[__] show you
[Laughter]
that's what it really was he's like I'm
a [__] you you don't even have the guts
to litter oh yeah
you wouldn't even litter at that and
she's like watch me [__] you or what if
she was like super goth dark arts
cosplayer and then like she got with
this guy because she thought like oh
he's a little crazy I like that and then
she's like wait you're actually crazy
you kill people oh I'm gonna [__]
call the cops it's because she just
wanted to cosplay vampire [__] not like
be a vampire she's a [__] poser
really
she wants to look like you'll never be a
virus she just watches Rob Zombie but
she doesn't really like murderers you
know and then for him he's all like oh
yeah she's gonna really love me when she
really sees that I'm a real [__]
murderer and then she's like I just like
watching murder documentaries I don't
want to [__] like be with one I wanna
[__] date Rob Zombie yeah see that's
true you know it's funny because uh
obviously us talking about how like
girls will ride everybody else you're
gonna tell your boys it's like this dude
did tell his boy
literally supported by the news yeah our
narrative supported by the [__] news
yeah what do you want what more do you
want what else could it be man it
happens every time not even our
narrative dude it's just us being
students of life and learning this truth
yeah ladies always snitch the ladies
always people always call them do you
think Jill would hold a cigarette for
you if you kill somebody hold a secret
yeah and not tell anybody or if you
think she would snap she should write
you out Geo actually secretly has a
penis she probably would keep the secret
wait what he's just telling the boys
yeah okay she's a little peepee yeah
she's a little peepee and I don't think
he's a little dude I don't think it's a
little bigger than barks I think it's
bigger than mine
watch the bodybuilder now that means his
dick gets smaller day by day literally
gets smaller around his body like if you
fall into my Ig in about two months he's
gonna be doing one of those [__] like
holds his underwear up like this and
there's nothing and you're actually as a
straight man you're still trying to see
what the schnapper I'm zooming in dude
when you do your bodybuilding
competition are you gonna have your your
little panties go over the hip or you're
gonna are gonna be below you gotta show
the beast but you just reminded me I
should have to order it I haven't even
ordered it yet wait what do you got to
order you again board shorts no you have
to banana hammock the banana hammock
when you actually have to order like a
specific it's such a good term for I
think don't we have the elephant ones
is there like a nude division where it's
like okay to just be naked everyone's
mature about it and they're not like
well with Bart all you have to do is to
say hey I'm a photographer it wants to
just drop them and then he will yeah uh
if Photoshop is so hard to do yeah is it
okay if you just [__] it yeah okay can
you bend over let's take a picture of
your butthole for the back
it's gonna be really good for the shoot
we're really just gonna focus on the
men's health part of it really it's for
the boys it's for the boys my mouse it
was not detecting I just I can't
Photoshop you sorry you just have to
leave it in I'm sorry man that reminds
me of that one Bobby Lee green screen
thing when he had to fight dragons but
he's like [__] sucking 20 dicks he's
jerk you stabbing dragons like this yeah
they got him good huh yeah I got him so
good yeah I'm good they did the man
dirty
[Music]